well Elizabeth Warren can't seem to go a
week without embarrassing herself which
is why I continue to hope and pray that
she wins a nomination in 2020 I really
do but this time she retweeted an
article about Dan Snyder buying a yacht
Dan Snyder's the owner of the Washington
Redskins and this is what she wrote when
she retweeted the article she said this
billionaire NFL owner just paid 100
million dollars for a super yacht with
its own IMAX theater I'm pretty sure he
can pay my new Ultra millionaire tax to
help the millions of yacht lists
Americans struggling with student loan
debt now I am by no means quick to
defend dan Snyder who is one of the
worst NFL owners probably in the history
of the league he has made many terrible
front-office decisions of course the
worst of which was when he paid Albert
Haynesworth 100 million dollars back in
2009 and then Albert Haynesworth went on
to get like two sacks and tears but
anyway that's besides the point and look
if you want to get on Dan Snyder's case
for how he spends money on the football
field how he how he spends money on free
agent contracts in everything then by
all means go ahead and do that but that
is not what Warren was getting at here
this was not a football criticism on her
part she a United States Senator is
simply shaming a private citizen for
being rich and buying a boat that's
that's what that's all about that's
that's all that was now here's the
question why is it any of Elizabeth
Warren's business that Dan Snyder bought
a boat with an IMAX theater why is that
any of her business what so the left
they're the ones who are always saying
mind your own business it's none of your
business stay out of my life stead so
why is this any of your business so the
guy by two bought a boat who cares what
does it have to do with you it's not
illegal what does it have to do with any
of us why should any of us have an
opinion about how dan Snyder spends his
money this is some of the the most
blatant and unapologetic
class warfare nonsense that you're
likely to see this is a senator
literally just posting a picture of a
rich guys yacht and saying look at this
a rich guy with his rich guy stuff
don't you hate all these rich guys um
and that's to say nothing of the
hypocrisy of it of course coming from
someone who is herself well-off she may
not be preparing to buy a yacht anytime
soon but she has luxuries that many of
us can't afford remember that hilarious
video of her drinking beer and trying to
pretend like an ought to be a normal
person here it is again remember this
God here so far um
Schuyler and 14 others hello Denise high
49 good to see you who else should we
got Kenny is that right Kenny and the
boys a grand you see is that gree me
goddess wow that's a name I'd like to
have okay so look at that did you see
that look at her at her kitchen did you
see her kitchen now that's a nice
kitchen that's a you got the nice
cabinets the nice fancy countertops what
are those like granite tile countertops
something now I think that personally
actually the green tile countertops are
hideous
but still those look like relatively
expensive countertops and she's got the
tile back the backsplash
you know most of us can't afford to have
tile backsplash right I think we can
agree that most Americans cannot afford
to have a kitchen like that I think
about this Elizabeth
Warren has that nice fancy kitchen
meanwhile a lot of people can't even buy
a car she's got the nice kitchen and
there are a lot of people you know that
are walking to work because they can't
afford to have a car so why should she
have such a nice kitchen with those nice
countertops and that backsplash when
there are people who don't have cars now
you might say that there's no connection
between the fact that some people don't
have cars and Elizabeth Warren's nicely
renovated kitchen you might say there's
actually no connection whatsoever so
this is a really stupid thing for me to
bring up and and you're right that's
exactly the point it is very stupid
there's no connection between Elizabeth
Warren's nice kitchen and the fact that
you can't buy a car and are broke just
like there's no connection between Dan
Snyder's boat and the fact that you have
college debt there there's no
relationship between those two things
whatsoever it's not like Dan Snyder has
some sort of magical funnel where when
you try to pay your college debt it
actually goes in the funnel and then
right into his pocket so that he can buy
a boat you know this isn't this isn't
this isn't like the movie there will be
blood with Daniel day-lewis explaining
how he's got a very long straw and he's
gonna drink your milkshake okay dan
Snyder is not drinking your milk shake
he's drift he's just drinking his own
milkshake he happens to have a much
bigger and nicer milkshake than the rest
of us but but still that doesn't take
away from the so the fact that I've got
this little tiny lame milkshake and he's
got this giant nice really delicious
milkshake that doesn't you could take
his milkshake away it wouldn't make my
milkshake taste any better that's the
point his richness does not harm you in
any way nor does it contribute to your
brokenness in fact if Dan Snyder went
bankrupt tomorrow not only would that
not help you but it would there's a good
chance that it may hurt you like if you
build gots for a living then it that
would hurt you if you if you work in the
in the Northern Virginia DC
it would hurt you inside if you work
retail or you work in a customer service
and that then that's a very rich person
who no longer has money to buy things so
that could hurt you if you work for him
he employs hundreds of people do you
work for me that could hurt you too so
take away his money and it helps no one
but it could hurt people that's that's
just a simple reality the best that you
could hope if you take away Dan Snyder's
money and make him so he so he's not
rich anymore the best you could hope is
that you live in some other part of the
country you don't work for him or work
in an industry that he patronizes and
then so it maybe it would help you in
the in the way that would satisfy your
envy you know make you just feel better
that someone else is suffering similar
misfortunes to you but there's no real
practical help there so that's one part
of this the other part is the whole idea
that the government needs to help
Americans who are struggling with
student loan debt honestly I am getting
really tired of hearing this particular
sad violin tune I am I have been invited
to this pity party many times and I just
I have no interest in it call me cruel
because they say that I lack charity I
lack sympathy that's probably the case I
don't care the fact is I am NOT crying
tears of sympathy because you have
student loan debt I'm just not I there
are a lot of things in the world that I
care about there are a lot of problems
that that trouble me there are many
forms of misfortune that I feel called
to you know help with and try to
alleviate your student loan debt is just
not one of those things I just really
that you could sit there so I have
$30,000 of student loan debt
here's the thing I really don't care I
just don't nobody does and and no one
should your student loan debt it's like
your credit card debt so if you went
complaining I got ten thousand dollars
in credit card debt okay I don't care
well how could you not care it really
hurts me to have all this cut well then
you should have bought all that stuff
a credit card what do you want me to say
I mean you got to pay it off as your
debts not mine
we all have debts okay we all have
financial challenges and things we have
to pay for I have a mortgage so I gotta
pay my mortgage in and sometimes it
really sucks to pay my mortgage I wish I
didn't have to pay but but I do I'm not
gonna go complain to you who my mortgage
is so high I don't want to have to pay
it I don't want to pay my mom no I'm not
gonna do that because I'm an adult
in fact I I have student loan I didn't
even go to college
and I have student loan debt Dipel I as
the as the wage earner in my household I
am paying off my whites wife's student
debt we've been paying her student debt
for four for seven years it's not even
my debt and I don't complain I don't
whine about it I don't complain about
I'm not gonna go complaining to you
about the fact that I'm paying off this
debt just is what it is you signed on
that dotted line you made a choice
that's your debt to pay that's all is it
an absurd amount of debt yes is college
way too expensive yes so is there
mercedes-benz but if you go and buy one
you got it then you bought it that's
yours you got to pay for it that's your
debt that you took on don't buy
something if you can't pay for it and
don't buy something that immediately
start crying but it's because you have
to pay for it it's like this is what
happens Kyle just say to the college
students okay here's how much it cause
sign on the dotted line and then the
student goes alright here we go
I'm signing and then as soon as they
make that last gesture of the pen and
they sign they immediately go wait why
is this so expensive it's not fair it
it's it's that expensive because that's
what you signed up for it and that's all
yes
it is College is absurdly expensive it's
too expensive but you volunteered for
that you didn't have to and you did so
that's all I just I I have a lot of this
is just exhaustion you know if if there
were people struggling with debt and
they weren't whining about it all the
time and trying to make himself out to
be victims and constantly complaining
and then even asking other people to pay
for it for them and supporting
politicians who have these student loan
forgiveness plans and all that if it
weren't for all of that then yeah maybe
I would feel sorry for people with their
with their debt just like actually if
someone has credit card debt and that
they've racked up and they you know
they've got $15,000 credit card debt and
they're not complaining about it or
whining or making themselves out to be a
victim but it's just a it's just now a
burden that they carry because they were
irresponsible with their credit cards
but now they're trying to pay it off
well that's someone that I would feel I
mean I still think that they should pay
it off but that is someone I would have
sympathy for because they're carrying
that burden with dignity and maturely
and not whining and so anyone who does
that anyone who carries a burden with
dignity and with maturity and who does
not expect other people to carry it for
them anyone in that category I have
sympathy for all of those kinds of
people all of whatever the whatever the
burden is even if it's a self-imposed
burden I mean you could you know you
could you could be in prison for
committing a crime and now you you're
dealing with your prison sentence and if
you are acknowledging that you're not
complaining you're not whining you're
acknowledging that this is what you
brought on yourself and so you're
serving out your term with ding then I
would have great sympathy for you as
well in that situation I think that's
that's that is deserving of sympathy
what I'm talking about are the people
who make a choice even if it was an
ill-informed choice a bad choice a
financially unwise choice whatever they
make that choice and now they're reaping
the consequences
and they're demanding sympathy and
constantly complaining about it that's
the issue and especially when they
expect other people to pay this idea of
student loan forgiveness which by the
way the student loan forgiveness is a
euphemism it's a misnomer it's not just
forgiveness no one can just forgive you
that you bought it someone's got to pay
for it that is a thing that you bought a
product I mean education is now a
product that you bought so if that loan
is forgiven that means someone else is
paying for it that's all it means and it
means that the taxpayers are paying for
it so the idea that taxpayers should
have to foot the bill for this thing
that you bought is so repulsively
immoral and stupid that I can't even
fathom it I cannot even a fathom the
selfishness and arrogance and just
cowardice of people who would who would
demand that someone else pay their their
student loan debt it's just it's
unbelievable to me yet this is very
common among people in my generation a
great matter the survey data in front of
me but a great there's a high percentage
of people around my age who think that
they are entitled to that and as I said
I find it repulsive ly immoral and
stupid that idea especially because
there doesn't even need to be a there's
no need for an especially here but I
will add and especially especially
because let's just be real about this ok
let's let's let's be honest one of the
primary reasons why people go especially
to these expensive for your institutions
because you could go to a community
college for two years and then if you
want more than a two-year degree you can
go and transfer your credits in most
cases and you know you could you could
cut your college tuition bill like in
half doing that but
they're also plenty of people who were
at really expensive colleges and they
could have gone to less expensive
colleges now most colleges are more
expensive than they need to be but not
all of them are astronomically expensive
there are cheaper options that you could
explore but a lot of people they want to
go to the expensive for your institution
and they want to be there all four years
they want to stay on campus they want to
do all that yes some of it's because
they've been told that this is how you
get a good job when you when you get out
of college but also because they want
the experience and they want the fun and
that's how college is sold to high
school students that's how the guidance
counselor's and the college recruiters
and everything that's how they sell it
it's not just about you'll get an
education you'll get a job there's that
but there's also it's a great experience
it's you know it's what you all your
friends are doing and it's it's it would
be a fun college experience you're never
gonna get that experience again four
years in college and yeah I can tell
based on what I've what I saw even
though I didn't go to college and based
on what any of my friends will tell me
it wasn't it wasn't it was a unique
experience you're never gonna have an
experience it is essentially like a
four-year vacation it is a vacation from
adulthood and from everything and you
just get the party all the time if you
want to and live in a way that you will
never be able to live again so great
great good for you but the fact that you
took on this debt in part because you
wanted that and now and now you're
complaining about it just be honest a
big part of the reason you wanted to go
to college because you want to have fun
I mean just be honest about it but you
can't be honest about it because then
you'd have to admit that you want us to
pay for this thing that you did because
it was fun so when it comes to people
who already
have that student loan debt and I've
already paid for it or they haven't paid
for yet but they've already signed on
the dotted line they've gone through
college and now they have the debt paper
the only thing we can really say to them
is and maybe there are nicer ways to put
it but basically the message is suck it
up buttercup and pay for it because
that's your I have debt you know a
mortgage is a lot of debt I have that
you know so if you have no mortgage but
yes to learn that I have more debt than
you do plus I've got my wife's debt so
and I'm not whining so you shouldn't
whine either
I don't expect your sympathy I'm not
going to give any to you you just be an
adult and deal with it all right now for
everyone else though
that's for the people who are already in
it and I've already made that choice now
they got to deal with it but when it
comes to kids who are getting out of
high school and who have not yet signed
on the dotted line well then I do think
our message to them should be very
different our message should not be yeah
sign on the dotted line and then suck it
up and deal with it if we can prevent
them from making that choice or get them
to think twice about it or consider
other options well that that would be a
very good thing let's see that's the
other problem is that we all complain
about how expensive college is but then
very few people want to consider the
other options so we all say yeah college
is really expensive it shouldn't be so
expensive but everyone should go to it
anyway well if that's the approach if
that's the attitude than it's never
going to get better college is never
going to get less expensive if we all
just send our kids there anyway
regardless the conclude
should be colleges really expensive it's
way too expensive so you should only do
that if you know if you have a plan in
mind and you know that that going to an
expensive four-year institution is a
necessary part of that plan that should
be our message to kids and it boggles my
mind that anyone would disagree with
this but a lot of people do even now
even now we all know how crushing the
student loan debt like a trillion
dollars in outstanding student loan debt
even in spite of that there are still so
many people say yeah you know what just
go and figure it out and you just go to
college and you'll figure it out what
you like it's such an a response an
irresponsible thing to do it's an even
more irresponsible thing to encourage
our kids to do the message to our kids
should be before you sign the sheet of
paper for the loan you should have some
idea about what your plan is and what
you're going to do with this and you
should have some idea as to whether or
not this really expensive four-year
academic vacation is actually necessary
for you maybe it is maybe you want to be
a doctor you want to be an engineer you
want to be an architect you know you
want to be a lawyer whatever there are
many things or vocations occupations in
life that would necessitate this in
which case absolutely but if you want to
do some
it's a little bit more hands-on if you
want to you know work you know in a
trade if you want to I mean there are
many other occupations that you might be
considering in which case that four-year
institution might be unnecessary it
might be a hindrance in the long run or
you might say I have absolutely no idea
I'm 18 years old I just kind of like
high school I have no clue what I want
to do with my life at all in which case
obviously you shouldn't just go right to
a college and and take on all that debt
without having any idea as to whether it
will emit will actually be necessary for
you in that case clearly the best path
is to go get a job for a while take your
time figure out what you want to do what
you're good at what your skills are what
your passions are and then at that point
if you realize that if for your
institution is necessary then you can go
and there's no disadvantage at all yeah
you're two years
you're a few years behind but what does
that even mean behind who behind what
and as you've fallen behind what you've
actually done is you've gotten some
real-world experience you've built a
little bit of a resume and you made some
money and you've saved some money and so
it's a it's a win-win in that case
alright let's go on to an update of a
story you remember last week with the
Covington saga a big part of that story
and especially depressing and shameful
part of that story was how some in
Catholic leadership bishops and so forth
came out right away to condemn the boys
not even waiting for the facts to come
in and one of the cowards who did that
was Bishop Roger Joseph Foy's whose the
Bishop of Covington and he turned his
back on the kids in his own diocese I
mean he's just threw them right out of
the bus had no leadership no courage at
all and then the facts came out and he
looked like not only a coward but a fool
so over the weekend or late last week he
issued an apology sort of
I'm going to read this sort of apology
to you from the bishop of Covington it
says my dear Covington Catholic parents
send Saturday 19th June January 2019 the
events at the Lincoln Memorial following
the annual March for Life have gained
international attention within hours we
were pressured from all sides to make a
statement regarding a video clip which
reportedly showed students for company
Catholics for high school being
disrespectful to Native American elder
Nathan Phillips based on what the video
clip showed we condemned the actions of
students who engaged in the alleged
disrespect and promised to investigate
the matter blah blah blah so on and so
forth we are sorry that this situation
has caused disruption in the lives of so
many we apologize to anyone who has been
offended in any way by either of our
statements which were made with goodwill
based on the information we had we
should not have allowed ourselves to be
bullied and pressure into making a
statement prematurely and we take full
responsibility for it
I especially apologize to Nicolas
Sandman and his family as well as to all
Cove CAF families who have felt
abandoned during this ordeal Nicolas
unfortunately has become the face of
these allegations based on video clips
that is not fair it is not just we now
await the results of the investigation
is my hope and expectations the results
will exonerate our students so that they
can move forward with their lives in any
event we will make the final report
public once it has been revealed in the
meantime we call on all those who
continue to spew venom and hate to
desist and instead pray for a peaceful
resolution to this tragic spectacle ok
so a couple problems here
first of all you're still invested what
is there to investigate what is this
investigation Intel you do you like CSI
out there doing fingerprint analysis
what what kind of investigation do you
need - it's on video look at the video
you could see what happened and that's
it you can clearly see that this your
students were being racially harassed
verbally assaulted by this other group
of the Nathan Philips came up and then
you could also see that he lied about it
so this is all clear to everyone there's
nothing to investigate
so saying well we're still investigating
this was just his way of getting out of
completely acknowledging that actually
he was totally wrong the students were
innocent and you know actually Native
American elder Nathan Phillips is a
bully and a liar
see the bishop doesn't want to
acknowledge oh he's trying to put that
off and so he says well we're still
investigating and his apology is really
Anana it's it's it's a classic non
apology
we apologize to anyone who was offended
we don't really necessarily apologize
directly for everything that we did and
we're not even acknowledging actually
that we were necessarily wrong we might
still have been right but we were a
little bit premature so if anyone was
offended that we apologize so it's kind
of a non apology but my biggest problem
is you're admitting that you allowed
yourself to be bullied by what some mean
Twitter come you're the Bishop of a
diocese and and you're admitting that
you were bullied by mean Internet
comments and not only were you bullied
into making a statement but it only took
like five minutes of bullying I mean
this statement from from Covington the
coming to Diocese came out within hours
so that's how quickly they caved and now
he's saying yeah you know what we really
were bullied there so what you're really
admitting is that you are a completely
spineless jellyfish without the without
the capacity to stand up against even
the slightest amount of pressure and the
problem is you're not alleviating that
impression now you're not really showing
that you've had a that you've changed
your ways because when the pressure was
when the public opinion was against the
students you came out and condemned them
and now that it shifted back in the
other direction you've come out and said
oh actually you know so you're still
just shifting with the winds is all and
you're still you've still got your
finger in the air trying to judge where
the wind is going and you're you're
still equivocating a little bit but just
that statement of we allowed ourselves
to be both we were bullied you know I
don't give you any credit at all for
acknowledging that yeah we know that
it's true but I give you no credit for
this apology and the very fact that you
could be bullied by internet trolls
bullied into throwing your own kids
under the bus I mean it's just shouts of
shameful and embarrassing and
unfortunately there's nothing now that
this Bishop can do he's just he's just a
coward and he's a fool and that's all it
did nothing is gonna change that that's
not gonna change that's just who he is
and I know you could say well but he
apologized what else did you know once
you apologized yeah apology is fine just
because you apologized that doesn't
necessarily change anything that doesn't
change who you are what you did and if
you're apologizing for being a gutless
coward well you're still probably a
gutless coward nothing has happened in
the last week to make you not a gutless
coward all right
get some of your emails if you want to
if you want to message the the show with
any comments questions concerns Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com so we'll go to the Inbox
now I thought there's some good some
good emails I wanted to talk about today
so this is from Bethany she says you
wondered why a quiet place was shut out
for Best Picture at the Oscars and
speculated that perhaps it's because of
the heroic father trope but no the
heroic father is allowed and even
somewhat encouraged lately in Hollywood
it is worth considering however that the
movie was a picture of an intact natural
family mother father children and also
that the climax of the picture involved
not only a father sacrificing his life
for his children but and this is
probably the real kicker a woman risking
her life to give birth to and save her
baby as the post as opposed to say
smothering the problematic thing at
Birth enough said
yes Bethany that is enough so I think
it's a great point actually I you know I
hadn't thought of that for some reason
but we were talking last week about the
really unimpressive collection of Best
Picture nominees for this year's Oscars
and their nominating like stupid comic
book movies about men in rubber suits
running around fighting bad guys when
there were actually good movies that
came out this year such as quiet plays
also first man also a movie called
hostels I think I was very good with
Christian Bale and and those movies were
all shut out quiet place why was it shut
out I think this is probably one of the
reasons it's got a very pro-life message
this is from
Jake he says I'm not necessarily a young
conservative but I do agree on many
ideas put forth by the likes of The
Daily wire and in general have a common
discontent for the double standards and
censorship of the social life what
advice would you give to someone like me
going into University where I'll face
almost guaranteed hostility from merely
supporting facts acting in a non
arbitrary way etc hi Jake well I'll just
say this briefly the left primary way of
shutting people down especially on
college campuses is simply to label them
racist homophobic bigoted sexist
whatever all the ist's and isms and
phobias so all you really have to do is
is remember that these are just words
they mean nothing they are the
equivalent of somebody trying to drown
out your opinion by plugging they're
using ears and making farting noises
that's all it is these labels are just
farting noises that's all you have to
think of it so ignore them be unfazed by
them and also just accept going into it
that you're probably not going to be
terribly popular on campus if this is a
liberal school and you don't share all
of their beliefs which it's required
that you do share as far as they're
concerned so if you don't then you're
not gonna be terribly popular but you're
gonna graduate and never see most of
those people ever again anyway so it
really doesn't matter I don't mean to I
don't mean to dismiss the challenges of
being a conservative or at least a non
liberal on a college campus I know it
can be very difficult but at the end of
the day all it really is is just them
shouting labels at you and being mean
and then who cares and then you'll
graduate you'll never see them again
doesn't matter this from anonymous says
I'm a minister in the United Methodist
Church which is taking a vote in
February for the inclusion of LGBTQ plus
clergy in the church this isn't just
about the gay issue it's also a
scapegoat for larger heresies
surrounding the historical Jesus a
literal resurrection and the authority
of scripture over our lives being
pro-lgbt in this context is often
synonymous with support for heretical
ideology is it possible to let the LGBT
agenda into the church
while also standing firm on scriptural
authority
I need direction I don't know if I
should stay well I'm sorry you're in
this difficult position I would say no
it's not possible at all to make the
LGBT agenda and scripture coincide it's
just not possible these are directly
opposed these are direct opposites in
order to accept homosexuality as good
and and you know virtuous or at least
morally neutral you would have to throw
out the many many scripture passages
that condemn it and you'd have to get
rid of the Gospels - because Jesus
specifically defines marriage as between
a man and a woman and you'd have to
throw out 2,000 years of Christian
teaching so what are you left with
you're not well you've thrown out all of
these books that Bible you thrown out
the Gospels you're thrown out Christian
teaching whatever few books and passages
you have left no longer there's there's
no longer any context or foundation for
them and there's no reason to believe
them or take them seriously because
you've discarded everything else so
that's why you just can't do it you
there's a choice has to be made either
we're gonna stick with Christian
teaching and the Bible and what the
Gospels say or we're going to adopt the
LGBT agenda so once a church says we're
going with the LGBT agenda it means that
they're tossing out the Bible and if I
was in that church I would be allow
myself to be tossed out right along with
it this from Brad he says hey Matt my
wife and I are expecting our second
child in May I was wondering if you have
any tips on naming kids Brad I have long
wanted to have a boy and named him mulch
okay which I think it's just a beautiful
name it's a it's a very rugged
it's an earthy name with some real just
substance to it right but we've had two
boys and my wife she just refuses for
some reason to name one of our boys
mulch so I am handing that name over to
you and really it could be it could be
it could go with either gender because
I'm progressive in that way so it is
yours now
cherish it finally well known I actually
finally got to mark this is from land
and he says Matt I saw on Twitter you
responding to that tweet from PETA
comparing eating sheep to eating dogs
here's my question why isn't it okay to
eat dogs what exactly would be the
problem with that not that I want to
I've just always been curious how we
decide which animals to eat and and
which not - yeah he's this there was a
PETA did one of their tried and true
publicity stunts I think was in
Australia where they pretended to roast
a dog wasn't a real dog but although it
could I mean PETA they do they do kill
hundreds of dogs and they're in their
shelters every year so you know but no
this was a this was a fake dog that they
were pretending to roast over a grill
trying to make some sort of stupid point
about hey if you're uncomfortable eating
a dog then you should be uncomfortable
eating sheep and pigs and cows and stuff
alright so but why don't we eat dogs
well it's purely a social convention of
course that that's all there's there's
nothing objectively wrong with eating
dogs they do it in other countries
obviously there's not some sort of
objective thing about dogs that makes
them more valuable than say pigs pigs
are intelligent four-legged mammals just
like dogs cows are less intelligent but
they're four-legged mammals so it's just
our social custom to eat cows and pigs
and and not dogs and that's all now I
have no desire to eat a dog but if I was
starving or something and there was a
dog nearby you're damn right I would
and if I was if I was visiting a foreign
country and someone served Fido Fido up
for for dinner if there was a dog stir
fry or something if there was like Rex
lasagna whatever it isn't that I would
eat it because I wouldn't want to be
rude but you know generally generally
when he talks but by the way but here's
the point when I call it a social
convention that doesn't mean that it's
necessarily arbitrary or meaningless
that's not what I mean in other words
even though I don't think there's
anything objectively wrong with eating a
dog and I would you know and I wouldn't
judge other cultures for eating dogs and
I wouldn't sit there and say no you have
to eat pigs instead because that's what
we prefer I would still agree that would
be really weird for someone in our
country to eat a dog unless they're
starving of course and that's because
the social convention stems from another
social convention which is to value dogs
above other animals to domesticate them
bring them into the family and so on and
so in that context it would be very
weird and inappropriate to eat one how
but there are some countries that simply
don't have that context that don't value
dogs the same way that don't that don't
just don't see them the same way and so
in that context they're fine t-this is
not moral relativism by the way as I
said the objective morality remains the
same I'm just talking about the general
appropriateness as the philosophers
might put it the what is most fitting so
I'm talking about what is most fitting
it is not fitting for us to eat dogs in
this country although it might be in
other countries finally an email from
someone that all call mark mark writes
in part hey Matt loved the show just
wondering if you could help me out on an
issue I'm 23 in a relationship for six
years
she is also 23 but we've been apart due
to University we're from Europe for
about four years worked together at the
weekends at all but I feel that after
six years I barely had one year of
complete experience with her I feel like
I don't really know her that deeply and
that makes me insecure about moving with
her moving in with her getting married
etc what you shouldn't move in with her
before
getting married because statistics show
that you know if you move in first and
your likelihood of divorce is much
higher so I would recommend cutting that
step out but anyway lately we've been
discussing some serious topics and I
noticed she doesn't care about factual
things that much all that matters is how
people feel in her opinion everyone is
right in their interpretation of the
world in situations therefore I cannot
judge or say someone is wrong according
to her I'm a Christian and a
conservative and I want to know if you
have any piece of advice on how I can
manage my relationships saying it's
doomed is also an option thank you for
your time all right well I'll put on my
doctor love hat here for just one second
so there are three issues here first of
all there's the distance the length
there so there's the distance there's
the length of time you've been together
and there's the apparent lack of shared
value so those are three different
issues as for the distance that's not
really an issue or it wouldn't be if
everything else lines up my wife and I
when we first met we were two and a half
hours apart it was it was a it was a
struggle but it wasn't it wasn't an
issue it wasn't anything that ever made
either of us consider breaking it off so
if everything else is right then the
fact that you've you know that you're a
few hours apart really isn't a big deal
lack of shared values well I will say
that is much more of an issue although
you know you say you talk about how
she's much more focused on how people
feel and she's more focused on on
feelings and emotions and all of that
well most women are like that to some
extent which isn't to say that they
don't care about facts at all but just
the reality is that women are more
relational and they're more focused on
on emotions the more empathetic at all
of that kind of thing and that's one of
the complimentary differences between
men and women that makes everything work
so I can tell you that that that my wife
being the empathetic one being the one
who's in touch with feelings and all
that stuff that's very good for me
because I struggle with that but however
if you lack a shared value system if
actually is a moral relativist which you
seem to also be implying and if you feel
like you are on the same page because
you're a Christian conservative and
she's not then that's something else
entirely and that is an issue that is an
obstacle it's not insurmountable I've
known plenty of people I've known of
plenty of people plenty of couples
who've been successful and happy
although that they although they come
from very different perspectives on on
really important things like religion
and and principles and all of that so
it's not necessarily a relationship
killer but it's a significant roadblock
and that brings us to the third thing
which is the length of your relationship
you've been together for six years like
if you've been with someone for six
years and you still don't know if you
want to marry them and if you're saying
well it's possible if the relationship
is doomed
still after six years then I would say
that's really not a good sign
I'm afraid because you should know
everything you need to know about a
person heading into marriage after six
years you should know it after six
months although for you six months you
would have been 17 or 18 so but
certainly after six years you know
everything you could possibly need to
know about someone before you marry them
assuming she isn't hiding some deep dark
secret like she's a serial killer or
something that aside you know everything
there is to know about her or everything
that you could know about her while only
dating now when you get married you
learn a lot more about a person you get
to know them in a much deeper way but
there's only so far you can go dating
with that because you haven't made that
commitment to each other and you haven't
made that vow so there's only so far you
can get and knowing someone and once
you've reached that point it's like
either you get married or you don't
there's no point in waiting anymore so
you just make the decision and certainly
after
you would know and so if you still have
doubts and reservations after six years
I would say maybe it's time for a
reassessment though of course that is
your decision to make
alright we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed